könnt ihr eigentlich noch ruhig schlafen
oder fürchtet ihr auch das böse erwachen
in einem rot-rot-grünen deutschland also
quasi im kommunismus die union verpasst
gerade keine chance das schreckgespenst
vom linksbündnis an die wand zu malen
als stünde der untergang deutschlands
kurz bevor es ist sehr sehr ernste
geschichte und wenn man das zusammen
rechnet diese diese mannschaft die dann
nach links außen spielt die wird unser
land gefährden das muss jeder wissen
innere sicherheit äußere sicherheit
europa nach oben glaubt denn
irgendjemand das ging mit der
linkspartei trotzdem sitzen frau eske
näher walter borjans kevin kühnert in
den gängen des bundestages in räumen
zusammen träumen von el zweig
keiner grenzt sich klar ab logisch dass
die union panik hat für die geht sehr
plötzlich auch um einen platz auf der
oppositionsbank aber natürlich steht
dieses geraune vom linksrutsch im raum
und vielleicht fragt auch ihr euch ist
es wirklich so dass da träumer von spd
linken und grünen zusammen sitzen und
schon heimlich den regierungswechsel
planen welche chancen hätte so ein
bündnis überhaupt und wäre mit den
linken überhaupt ein staat zu machen
[Applaus]
mein name ist andrea maurer ich bin
politische korrespondentin im zdf
hauptstadtstudio eins ist klar er zweig
also rot rot grün auf bundesebene
das wäre historisch neu und nach den
aktuellen zahlen grundsätzlich möglich
im politbarometer kommt die spd auf 25
die grünen auf 17 und die linke auf 7
prozent
[Musik]
voraussetzung für eine koalition ist
vertrauen zwischen den parteien
vorangegangene gespräche kontakte
beziehungen gibt es die bei rot rot grün
haben die sich wirklich schon verbündet
die vielleicht bemerkenswerteste
rot-rote freundschaft ist die zwischen
jan korte und carsten schneider beide
sind parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der linken und der spd das sind die die
hinter den kulissen im parlament
wirklich die arbeit machen hier ein
privates foto der beiden die zwei gehen
gerne zusammen angeln und bier trinken
ich habe hier in cortina gefragt wie
diese freundschaft eigentlich zusammen
geht immerhin ist konnte ein
eingefleischter linker und carsten
schneider gehört dem seeheimer kreis an
das ist der stramm konservative flügel
der spd erstmal ist als echte er
schwierigere flügel der spd das ist erst
mal einfach so richtig politisch aber
ich glaube es gibt natürlich eine
bestimmte altersgruppe auch hier in den
bundestag und glaubt carsten und ich
sind in etwa so die dieselbe
alterskohorte wie man heute so schön
sagt und da verbindet einen natürlich
als erstes verbindet uns natürlich unser
gemeinsames hobby nämlich dass wir
angler sind und das per se schon mal
ganz sympathisch aber es ist natürlich
auch wir gehen den die ähnlichen kneipen
hey das sind ja echte kumpels und das
ist wirklich selten in der politik nutzt
das eigentlich auch ihren parteien wenn
man natürlich auch ein bisschen
freundschaftlichen rat hat ist es ja
total spannend dass man auch mal auf dem
kurzen dienstweg einfach miteinander
telefoniert oder mal ein bierchen
zusammen trinken geht und sagt ey wie
läuft's bei dir wie ist die stimmung in
deinen laden wie bei dir also das hatte
schon vorteile um auf sich gegenseitig
ein bisschen auf dem laufenden zu halten
ja das nutzt glaube ich da geht doch was
oder was meint ihr diese freundschaft
jedenfalls könnte sollte es zu
sondierungsgesprächen kommen sehr
nützlich sein so vieles klar aber wie
steht es generell um die freundschaft
zwischen spd linken und grünen 2016 gab
es dieses legendäre rot-rot-grüne
treffen ca 90 abgeordnete von spd linken
und grünen sondieren gemeinsamkeiten bei
breze wein und bier viele bekannte
gesichter aus allen drei parteien dabei
auch der damalige spd parteichef sigmar
gabriel das war nach jahren in denen spd
linke und grüne selbst bei rechnerische
mehrheiten also 2005 und 2013 keine
koalition gebildet haben ein echtes
ereignis tja diese tage sind schon
wieder vorbei nach solchen bildern sucht
ihr heute vergeblich vor allem auf
spitzenebene ist die rot-rot-grüne
begeisterung schon wieder erlernt woran
das liegt das habe ich den spd
bundestagsabgeordneten axel schäfer
gefragt der seit jahren spitzentreffen
zwischen spd linken und grünen
organisiert um vertrauen durch gespräche
zu schaffen es liegt vor allem an der
parteispitze der grünen sagt schäfer im
frühjahr hatte er ein treffen von
berbalk esken und kipping organisiert
und dann ist das passiert und dann hat
vorburg erst zugesagt und dann abgesagt
ohne begründung und das war für mich
schon persönlich sehr betrüblich sie
erklären sich das ja auf der einen seite
das damals im februar eine ganz klare
ausrichtung von vielen grünen
politikerinnen und politiker an der
parteispitze auf schwarz-grün
ausgerichtet war möglichst keine debatte
über rot grün rot und und auf der
anderen seite
dass man sorge hatte dass das ein
mobilisierungsthema ist eine eine
mehrheit gegen die union und das mann
war an der stelle einfach ängstlich oder
vielleicht auch über taktisch
gescheitert also wohl vor allem an
annalena baerbock die damals voll auf
schwarz grün setzte und wohl angst vor
rot-rot-grünen signalen hatte und was
sagen die grünen dazu michael kellner
der wahl 2016 bei diesem legendären
rot-rot-grünen treffen dabei heute ist
der wahlkampfleiter der grünen und wir
haben ihn gefragt wie aktuell seine
sympathien für die linkspartei sind ja
ich weiß einfach nicht ob sie ob sie
regierungswillig ist und ob die die
fraktion ist die abgeordneten ist eine
sehr macht ja oft ein gespaltenen
eindruck und deswegen nehme ich sie da
als wackelkandidaten war so viel zum
vertrauen dass es für koalition braucht
die regierungs begeisterten grünen 9 mit
den schmuddelkindern von der linken
gerade echt nichts zu tun haben und
damit zu einer frage die sie in der
union ja gerade gerne und oft stellen
wäre mit der linken überhaupt ein staat
zu machen
[Musik]
selbst axel schäfer ihr erinnert euch
das ist der der diese rot-rot-grünen
spitzentreffen immer organisiert hat der
hat inzwischen da so seine zweifel grund
ist diese abstimmung im bundestag zum
bundeswehr-einsatz evakuierung aus
afghanistan bei der sich die linken
mehrheitlich enthalten haben den linken
ist diese enthaltung ganz schön um die
ohren geflogen so richtig gut erklären
konnten sie das ehrlicherweise auch
nicht die linke hat sich enthalten zu
einem zeitpunkt als dieser einsatz de
facto doch schon beendet war und wir
haben kritisiert dass man es viel zu
spät gemacht hat dass man viele menschen
im stich gelassen hat und auch dass man
die soldatinnen soldaten einer gefahr
ausgesetzt hat die nicht nötig gewesen
wäre aha die logik da der einsatz schon
geschlossen war konnte man sich auch
enthalten ob die linke in
regierungsverantwortung sich im fall
einer militärischen evakuierungs
operation über ihren pazifismus
hinwegsetzen würde um menschen zu retten
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht und ich
glaube spd und grüne wissen es eben auch
nicht so und jetzt nochmal ans
eingemachte regieren einen staat führen
geht das mit der linken oder geht das
nicht was spricht dafür in sozialpolitik
klimapolitik wohnpolitik könnten sich
spd linke und grüne ganz bestimmt
annähern eine große rentenreform wie
scholz geplant wären mit grünen und
linken sicher besser zu machen als mit
union und fdp nicht ganz unwichtig
immerhin sagen 51 prozent der befragten
in unserem politbarometer soziale
gerechtigkeit sei wichtig für ihre
wahlentscheidung was spricht dagegen
richtig viel vor allem die linke außen
und sicherheitspolitik das verhältnis zu
russland china zu venezuela
das nein zu bundeswehreinsätzen im
ausland das nein zur nato es ist
eigentlich kaum denkbar dass es in
deutschland ein minister oder eine
ministerin gibt die nato nicht anerkennt
es geht also um verlässlichkeit einer
regierung braucht stabile mehrheiten
natürlich gibt es in der linkspartei
leute die kompromiss bereits sind
dirigieren wollen aber es gibt eben auch
die anderen und wie kompromissbereit der
hart gesottene teil der linken
bundestagsfraktion ist das kann keiner
so genau sagen also dass rot-rot grün im
bund noch nie gab wäre das ein
experiment mit offenem ausgang bleibt
die frage warum die union wieder diese
rote socken kampagne fährt und wie die
spd reagiert
[Musik]
ihr herz vielleicht mitbekommen auch die
kanzlerin macht jetzt wahlkampf endlich
könnte man sagen aber nicht für den
unions kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet
sondern gegen ein linksbündnis die
kanzlerin steigt also für ihre partei in
panik noch mal in den ring sie hat sich
dabei für einen schweren schlag gegen
olaf scholz entschieden denn der hat ja
in den letzten wochen vor allem die
merkel sie kennen mich karte gespielt
nix da sagt macke wenn man sozusagen
sich auch nicht beruft ist einen
unterschied gibt mit mir als
bundeskanzlerin wurde es nie eine
koalition geben in der die linke
beteiligt ist und ob dies von olaf
zugeteilt wird oder nicht das bleibt
offen und in dem zusammenhang ist es
einfach so dass da ein gewaltiger
unterschied für die zukunft deutschlands
zwischen mir und ihm besteht merkel
macht also ihren vizekanzler und
finanzminister zur roten gefahr die
cdu-parteizentrale setzt jetzt voll
drauf diese wahl zu einer zitat
richtungsentscheidung zu machen dieses
wort höre ich gerade oft in
unionskreisen und der generalsekretär
ist seit tagen was das zeug hält gegen
hashtag link republik hashtag
linksrutsch für eine solche anti links
kampagne musste die union eigentlich nur
in die archive steigen von adenauers
alle wege des marxismus führen nach
moskau von 1953 bis hin zur sogenannten
rote socken kampagne
meist geht es um das böse erwachen in
einem kommunistischen rückständigen
deutschland und darum konservative
wählerinnen und wähler zu mobilisieren
und wie reagiert die spd dass olaf
scholz ja eigentlich kein freund von rot
rot grün ist nicht nein zu dieser
koalition sagt das hat drei strategische
gründe erstens es gibt einen
parteitagsbeschluss von 2013 nach der
einer koalition mit der linkspartei auf
bundesebene möglich ist deshalb kann
olaf scholz einer solchen koalition vor
der wahl gar keine absage erteilen 2 die
nächste fraktion der spd könnte jünger
und klinker sein rot-rot-grün
auszuschließen würde also den linken
flügel der partei womöglich verbrennen
der dritte und wichtigste grund scholz
braucht rot rot grün als option um
koalitionsverhandlungen mit der fdp
besser führen zu können rot rot grün
macht die spd zu der partei die in fast
allen denkbaren konstellationen den
ausschlag gibt fakt ist zum ersten mal
wird die linkspartei an
sondierungsgesprächen auf bundesebene
wohl beteiligt sein die linkspartei
jedenfalls ist regelrecht euphorisch
seit der kampagne der union wir sind
wieder im spiel sagen sie in der partei
und sind doch eigentlich der fünf
prozent hürde gerade verdächtig nach aus
eigener kraft haben sie es jedenfalls
nicht geschafft jetzt sprechen wieder
alle über sie auch wir hier
[Musik]
also wer hat angst vor rot rot grün und
jungen fdp klar weil die nicht zum
regieren camp die grüne parteispitze
weil sie doch eher konservativ tickt
olaf scholz weil es womöglich ernst
werden könnte und vielleicht sogar die
linkspartei selbst weil sie die
hardliner in ihren reihen
regierungsfähig machen müsste und ihr
habt ihr auch angst diskutiert gerne mit
und schreibt unten in die kommentare
schreibt doch auch welche themen euch
noch interessieren würden hierbei inside
politics und wenn ihr nichts mehr
verpassen wollt dann abonniere doch
unseren kanal zdf heute